reality the apprenticeship board
in the past was given the authority
to approve registered apprenticeships in
the state
and that's that authority has been taken
by the the federal government now
since 2007 um and so
the the effort here is really just to
square the existing state law on
apprenticeship
with the the reality of federal control
over this
so everything in these sections i see
some strikeouts
those are things that the federal
government has taken over
and you no longer can do is am i correct
that is correct all right you wanted
before i opened it to
questions you want to go back to what mr
hoffman said about the previous couple
of
sections uh certainly uh if you can
remind me which
which topics uh because i don't have i
don't have the material in front of me i
was just
i was just listening again i think this
is i think mr hall was pretty clear
section 125 your workers comp
strikes fiscal year in the preceding
calendar year so it just says
in the preceding calendar year which
makes sense and then down below
it struck the word words two words the
work so it says
per damn for each day devoted to
hearings of the board
we are assuming you're working and then
you no longer have to mail
certified return receipt but instead it
will be either first-class mail or
upon the consent of parties by
electronic transmission
and you are okay with those i
absolutely we requested these uh
all in all instances the language that
we've requested in house bill 2
uh again squares us with
actual practice the department has
for years been conducting its business
in this way and in fact in some
instances we were cited
by the legislative budget assistant in
in financial audits
for not doing things according to
statute
and uh so this is this is my effort to
to square us with with state law the
things that the department has been
has been doing for a number of years the
with regard to the change from
fiscal year to calendar year we've got
a number of different uh
factors involved in those assessments
and it would actually this isn't a
simpler change than having to change
some of the other
procedures that we have uh if i can
how can i do this in a few words uh the
the
um self-insured workers comp
those entities report to us because of
because of statute
and administrative rule they report
their claims to us
on a calendar year basis the insurance
department has been
giving us carrier information in the
same way
for a number of years and so our
assessments for these two
funds that you see represented in house
bill 2
uh have been calculated based on
calendar year claims
and and we're just trying to make the
statute read
in a way that's that's appropriate for
what our practice is
okay so we have mrs lavinas followed by
representative welts
yesterday manager thank you um on the
line one yep this was just something i
noticed yesterday
the language uh beginning in the middle
of that line
page on line one such per diem shall be
per rated to an
hourly rate for other related work
performed by board members
um and i thought i believe that's just a
typo in the bill but i want you to
okay can we i can make a note of that we
can change that
at any time is that something we can do
in a row in enrolled bills as opposed to
getting an amendment
at the end of the budget process the
finance committee generally votes to
allow the lba to make technical
amendments that do not affect
substance perspective is that works
something like that so we can hear that
make a note of that
represent walls yes i'm concerned with
what it is that we are no longer
requiring certified mail for
and i just want to have a clear
understanding of that so that we're not
violating the due process rights of
people so if somebody could explain
clearly to me i mean it's hard to do
this during the hearing
of exactly is it that there's going to
be a hearing is it an appeal of a
hearing what is it that we no longer
if if i might uh it is it is
it is uh a notice of hearing
and and again uh as i as i mentioned
earlier
this is to square the statute with what
the actual practice
here at the labor department has been
for decades
we have not been sending these here
notices certified mail
if we did it would represent an
extraordinary increase in costs
for the department uh they have been
using u.s
mail here for for as long as anyone here
can remember
uh may i follow up follow up so if if
a person defaults on this
is there any attempt to follow up
through certified mail or any way
of trying to understand why they
defaulted at the perhaps the mail didn't
get to them or
what happens if there's a default yes
certainly
there there are additional contacts
attempted certainly
and are you i guess what i'd like to say
is if we're not going to use certified
mail
i want to put i want to codify the fact
that there must be
some sort of additional contacts if
there's a default because
i have heard too many stories perhaps
not on this particular issue but around
the state of people going so far as to
lose their house because
there was not proper notification
because it was sent first class mail to
a prior residence
they didn't get notification and
literally a default judgment
had just taken their house from them and
this isn't
represented walls this is not about
mortgages
i understand that but this is very
limited but it's the same principle
people need to have notification other
than straight up mail because default
judgments are very harmful
and i just want to have some sort of
recognition in here that if there's a
default
that the the um commissioner or his
agency has an obligation to follow up as
to why there was a default that it's
why don't we find out for mr mayorfield
if they ever have a default
to see if we even have that issue mr
mayorfield you understand
her concern even though you're not a
mortgage can you
explain for us if you have a default and
if so what the
process is yeah i i think i think
it's worth a mention that that any
decision
made by our department in the hearings
bureau
has has numerous appellate uh avenues to
pursue
um i mean i could i could get you more
information
from the heroes hearings bureau
administrator
about what happens and what additional
efforts are made to
to contact people but i would just
reiterate again
this has been our practice for decades
to use only u.s mail
so so it's not a change in practice
certainly and and i think we have to
consider at least
the the financial implications for the
department the the hearings bureau uh
administrator recommended this language
to us i asked you know my
managers to alert me to situations where
statute
required something that was not
efficacious to current practice in the
department so that's why we raised this
i'm happy to get more information for
you about
you know what what is happening but but
it is
it is the actual practice of the
department for as long as anyone can
remember
thank you i'm not interested in asking
the department to unnecessarily spend
money on postage i'm fine with first
class postage in the majority of cases
i just wanna clear that
in the case of a default where somebody
is not making an appearance after
hearing has been
been scheduled that there is some
obligation on the
part of the department to do additional
matters and i think
that needs to be codified not just a
recognition of practice because there's
no guarantee it's going to happen that
if we codify it that there's an
obligation on the behalf of the
department i think then
there's no problem with no longer
requiring certified mail that's not
being done anyway but i want to make
sure
that anybody has appropriate notice
that's basic due process and if we don't
do that we can be sued
mr mayfield will you get us one
the additional information and two
will you let us know what the practice
has been since you've been doing this
for decades
you surely have one or two people who
didn't get to a hearing
in a decade long process and if you
could send that information to
janet clayman she will get that to all
of us and we would appreciate that
absolutely thank you in that case
can we approve sections 125
126 and 127
which stops prior to the section
of that mr mirrorfield is going to get
us more information so we're going to
representative emery moves the approval
of sections 125
1826 127 representative leishman seconds
mr mayfield do you need to say anything
on that or are you okay with that
i'm i'm absolutely okay with that uh
does
uh what i'm one question though uh what
you've cited does that
uh reference the per diem language
yes it does but you heard what mrs
lavina said
that we do move at the end of the budget
hearings to allow
lba to make some technical
corrections and she has noted that as
one that needs to be made so it will be
taken care of without having a separate
amended
amendment by us okay okay uh
yes then then i am fine with all of that
okay great
and you'll get us information okay so on
the motion
to approve sections 125
126 and 127
if you're in favor you will say yes or i
if you're opposed no or nay represents
okay uh okay if you're in favor you're
voting affirmative if not a negative
madam chairman the vice chairman
representing emmerich
uh the clerk votes yes representative
griffin
okay representative hatch yes
representative waltz
yes okay affirmative madam chairman okay
we are unanimous in approving those
ken will wait for that additional
information thank you for being online
this morning
or this afternoon and we'll continue to
work with you
absolutely thank you
bob i just promoted you to be a panelist
you're
up next for des and i don't know which
of your other staff you would like to
have promoted
with you uh if uh mike if you don't mind
sue carlson
this is bob scott s-c-o-t-t sue carlson
c-a-r-l-s-o-n
juni anybody else bob i have the
division director standing by i don't
envisioning
needing them but uh they're there in
case you need to you know we have
questions and
you'll be able to promote them at that
time well you know what i see my guam
stat here i'm going to move him over
i see renny i'm going to move him over
who knows who you're going to need
okay i see tom donovan o'donovan
and he's coming so budgeting is
truly a team sport is that what you're
saying it is a team sport and to make it
worse
don't and no offense but the speaker
wants to see me at two o'clock so
my very able vice chairman
representative emerick will continue the
hearing we don't want to have
to invite you back just because my
schedule changed so
welcome thank you for coming
and we'll let you take it away mr
hoffman brought up your
handouts at lunchtime so we have those
in front of us
excellent well thank you for that so i
will refer to the handouts and since
they're not on the screen for you
and you have them live i'll try to
remember to um
no the lba is going to put them up on
the lba website
everybody will be able to access them in
a digital format
so even though you're not sharing your
screen everybody will be able to see
them
excellent excellent madam chair they are
already up
so should i start matter chair
please okay thank you so uh
again uh thank you for having us uh
as as uh the chair has mentioned i have
our chief operating officer
susan carlson uh with me as well as
uh division directors and assistant
director pelletier so
uh we hope to be able to answer any
questions you should have
i'll move on to slide two for the slide
deck that you have
uh and i won't dwell on this too much
but just just to give you an idea of the
layout of our agency
uh for those who aren't aware
and again i can however the chair would
like i can answer questions on the flyer
at the end
uh i'll move to slide three which is our
mission statement
uh again hopefully you're all familiar
with that which is to protect
the environment public health in new
hampshire uh
some of our core functions uh which is
this the next slide
slide four uh representative walsh you
no i don't think she does her hand went
down oh okay
so of late uh you we've the department's
been as
has much focus on water infrastructure
wastewater
issues and contamination issues so we
have other core functions but those have
really been the
the driving factors of late uh moving to
slide
five uh we detail that a little bit more
you know i'll talk some more about some
of these things so for example for
uh water uh contamination especially
uh uh obviously pfas is the four letter
word that
uh that we have of late uh we
also have uh we'll discuss later in the
minutes in the budget
uh a new fund that was created uh last
fighting m for bonding
authorized bonding of up to 50 million
dollars for
pfas issues for as a loan fund
uh so that's uh you know related in a
newer thing
for infrastructure the drinking water
groundwater trust fund
is a relatively new and ongoing
initiative and then of course the
drinking water and clean water
state reloading loan funds uh have been
uh
very uh you know they've been
oversubscribed uh and are very i think
impactful to the communities so with
that i'll go to slide
six and again just for some of our
budget highlights
uh you know overall our budget is just
shy of 255
million dollars for 22. uh we're showing
uh 489 uh authorized positions
uh 89 of those at the moment are are
vacant
uh and uh you'll see uh
there's over 115 federal grant
and uh over 40 dedicated funds within
within the agency just to kind of
orient the committee uh moving to slide
seven uh our presentation uh for the
slides will certainly
mostly focus on uh fiscal year 22 budget
it's it's pretty
close to what our 23 budget is uh
and to give you some perspective uh our
ceo sue carlson uh has created some of
the
some of the pie charts you'll you'll see
here as you come through uh
so percentage-wise again just to orient
the committee
we are roughly nine percent general
funds
uh nearly half of that is uh state aid
grants to the communities
uh 23 is federal funds or
close to 60 million dollars uh 68
is other funds so if we break that down
that
uh 172 million dollars uh
the the mostly clean water state
revolving loan fund
uh payments are about 27 percent of that
uh the 22 is the drinking water
groundwater trust fund
uh the waste fee programs account for
31 percent of that proportion the water
fee programs another 14
the air fee programs about five percent
in the commissioner's office another two
percent
uh so looking at that overall the state
revolving loan
fund programs are about 35 of our
overall budget
so moving on to slide eight uh also to
see how the funds are used
uh the operating budget is about 25
percent salary and
benefits nine percent is operating
expenses
uh service debt uh and other
miscellaneous
uh that leaves about two thirds of our
budget again for grants and loans
contracts and oil fund uh reimbursements
uh loans is our largest category at 39
of of that so i'll move on
uh for the interest of time to slide
nine
uh this is broken up by uh divisions
uh as you see the water the water
division
is about 53 percent of uh the entire
budget
and about 53 percent of the staff
waste division uh is about 40
at 102 million dollars and the air
division in the commission's office make
up the remaining 7 percent
uh or roughly about 118 staff combined
uh moving on to slide 10 uh
you'll you'll see that the fiscal year
22 growth
uh is primarily due to the creation of
our
the emergent contaminant emerging
contaminant
program in the waste management division
so that will be on page
834 of your book i believe that's what
you're looking at
uh and in the last biennium
des was granted six million dollars out
of the drinking water groundwater trust
fund for investigation of pfas issues
uh in testing and uh some work on that
end and again as i mentioned uh in last
planning
allowed us to do bonding for up to 50
million dollars for a pfas loan program
uh that was part of the house bill four
uh ultimately uh so des added 15 million
dollars
per year to this operating budget
request
uh and uh with the same
with that we also decreased some uh
other contract appropriations by uh
three
almost four million dollars so uh the
increase in
grants as you see is due to uh the
drinking water groundwater trust fund uh
which is on page 833
uh that was a 4.5 million dollar
increase
uh again we had some smaller reductions
from other programs
uh one new federal grant to draw your
attention to
uh is the data is a line is on
page 787 and that's for dam assessments
so the budget shows a million dollar
increase for consultants
uh that's to use federal funds to
perform uh
a fairly detailed engineering assessment
uh
and design work on uh state-owned flood
control dams uh
that were originally constructed by the
national resource conservation service
uh and particularly the three dams on
the south eakin river watershed
so that i'll draw your attention to that
because that that is a
significant change uh with that and
also um compared to 20
for 22 there's a three percent increase
uh
regarding salary and benefits uh and
then in 23 uh
due to the 27th pay period there was a
further increase
uh for for fiscal year 23. i assume all
the state agencies are showing that
um i'll move on to slide 11.
um and if i'm going too fast please
please tell me
uh so slide 11 this table shows how the
department's broken down again by
funding source
uh the general funds uh decreased
roughly by 12 primarily due to
reductions in salary and benefits
contracts grants and and that decrease
continued until 2020
excuse me the 23 fiscal year budget
the trust fund the groundwater drinking
water groundwater trust fund
uh increased
with grants and all others uh
on the on the slide there uh increases
uh again that's the emerging
contaminants account i just talked about
that's a roughly 10.2 million dollar
increase plus minor increases for
uh other fee accounts um
so i'll move on to slide 12. uh
so answering the the chair the chair's
questions
uh that was transmitted to us so the
first question is what new full-time
positions have been added to the budget
uh this is a slide showing that i'll
uh the following slides will detail
those individually
so i'll move on to slide 13. so under
new positions
uh answering question number one um
so this this is for uh
our public information center we get a
fair amount of traffic for
uh information requests uh particularly
under 91 a
request so we were looking to staff that
a little bit better
with the program assistance so that's
the
one of the five uh requests we have in
this new
this budget uh request the moving to
slide 14
are our one stop uh which is the the
term we use for our
combined databases and public-facing
um services that we provide on the web
uh there's a fair amount of work needs
to be done to that that's a
really a result of 20 years of for
one of a better technical word uh
conclusion together
individual databases that have been made
by the programs over the year to help
years to help serve the public uh those
are all housed
uh together under what we call our one
stop uh database
uh that needs a lot of work uh and and
to be um
uh to be uh able to be used in the
future
uh we're looking for a business systems
analyst to help with that
that effort uh moving to uh
slide 15 uh our wastewater engineering
bureau
is also looking for some uh extra
support for the work
they do uh that's the uh
and again they have the clean water srf
there's a
certain amount of oversight for the
construction that goes along with that
and to the extent that state aid grants
uh
happen we have similar issues on that as
an example
bob could you go back to one stop for a
minute certainly
first bullet talks about one stop
and then last bullet talks about new one
stop
are you upgrading writing new what's
going on
we are hoping to and if you look at the
capital budget we also have
funds in there to to revamp one stop
so i give you an example so last
uh kovitz put a a
stop in my time clock here but uh if i
go back a little over a year ago
uh we had an issue where doit
had their contractor had done some uh
some scans if you will and as it turned
out that most of our database under what
one stop uh the coding that it was
created with uh
actually had uh allowed for
vulnerabilities for cyber security so we
end up having to bring the system down
while they recoded uh really as a as a
band-aid uh because we were under a time
crunch because people needed the service
to to
at least get that system so it wouldn't
have the same vulnerabilities
so that that whole system really needs
to be revamped and redone
uh again some of the databases are you
know approaching on 20 years
as you well know a lot happens
especially in this kind of technology so
uh that's what we're referring to is our
new new one stop so we have some cap
capital budget requests as well uh and
this would help support that
thank you
[Music]
so i'll go back to remember where i was
here
um i think i talked about the wastewater
engineering bureau position
and going to uh slide 16
is an environmentalist position uh to
help with
residential well drinking water issues
so more than
roughly 50 of all the wells uh
all the drinking water in our state
comes from private wells uh
and with the uh contaminated excuse me
contamination issues we've been finding
uh statewide uh we're really finding
that to be a
an area where we need to provide more um
more focus on so that's an attempt to
help help that
so and again so now i'll go to slide 17.
so as i mentioned for one stop our waste
management division also
uh could do with some help uh
the one stop is department-wide uh but
we're also looking at
uh needs within that division
more specifically for database work uh
you know the good news
we're finding as we do database work uh
the public generally certainly the
regulated public too
uh really start to depend on that so the
good news is as we start to do it the
more they want
and the the bad news is uh and you can't
backtrack understandably because people
start to depend on this type of thing so
we're
we're trying to provide that service it
not only helps obviously the
the public but it helps the agency run
more efficiently also
so moving to slide 18
the letter the chair had sent also asked
question number three is what positions
did we have to eliminate to meet the
governor's budget requirements so
uh what we did do is under the national
pollutant discharge elimination system
or niptis
and the small municipal separate storm
sewer system or ms4 programs
uh last biennium i think it was uh
biennium before we had some positions
created
to help uh the agency and uh more
explicitly the municipalities
to provide assistance uh for those
federal programs so
the the ms4 program in particular uh
if you look at a map of the state would
cover
uh the the southern part of the state uh
south south east part of the state so a
lot a lot of municipalities
uh this particular position would be for
a financial
analyst that's something the agency
typically doesn't have in our
in our quiver of uh tools and
this is intended to help that uh those
uh help to help the agency help the
municipalities uh
to uh look at their requirements and how
can they
uh more effectively and cost effectively
uh meet the federal requirements so uh
given the the fiscal constraints of
covid
we elected not to to fund this position
we absolutely do
want the position uh and and ideally we
would like it
but uh given the financial
considerations when we were developing
the budget
uh we hope that the position is able to
stay but yet
uh we could live a biennium without
funding the position so that's what
you'll see
in slide 18.
slide 19 answers the questions
about effectively uh paraphrases can we
do our job
and meet state law with the budget
and as as requested and the short answer
is yes we think we can
uh we have again the five positions
we've asked for
in this budget uh the real issue is
going to be
as i mentioned currently we have 86 open
positions
is recruiting and and getting those
positions filled but uh
pending that yes we we do feel uh we
will
continue to be able to do our job slide
is a question about have we found any
laws
that we think should be eliminated uh
short answer is
not at this time uh we are uh
a place where the agency is not bashful
about talking to legislators so if we as
we do see something that could be
either streamlined or certainly
eliminated uh
you know that we understand that we
should be coming forward to you all
uh as a legislative body uh on
page excuse me slide 21 uh
answers uh question number seven uh for
what priorities were not
funded uh so i will refer
that we have three three on our priority
needs list uh
that weren't funded uh originally in the
governor's budget
uh i will i assume you've all seen the
governor's
uh letter to you all of the third of
march
uh so there's on the slides
are three uh items there's actually a
fourth item
uh which was added and is on the
governor's list on that three march
letter
uh so since that's not on the the next
slide i'll talk about it now so that's a
mercury analyzer
uh so that's 55 000
uh so the background of that is uh
almost all the new hampshire water
bodies uh are mercury impaired
uh and we know this because we've had
basically about a 30-year data record
for that and we have statewide mercury
advisories
uh for the state uh
in fact last year we added more fish
species to the advisory list
so this this ana the current analyzer we
had is really
uh absolutely at the end of his useful
life
and it's is uh as you may imagine uh
after a while that you can't get parts
for
some of these old analyzers so uh that
was an ask we
we had of late and that is in the
governor's uh
uh letter of third the third of march
uh so what is in the slides uh is uh on
that prioritized needs list
is uh slide number 22. so we had a
request
for some consulting work to help our
wetlands program
uh get e-permitting get closer to be
able to do an e-permitting
system we also had
which is item a on slide 22 and then
we also had requests for
maintenance activities at our superfund
hazardous waste sites
and then item c is for a four wheel
drive vehicle to help support that
program also
slide uh 23 there was
questions also in the chairs letter to
us
about house bill 2. so
i we took the liberty here of uh talking
about state aid grants so
uh state a grants and house bill 2 uh
continues a moratorium on um
on state aid grants
what we we bring up here there are
multiple bills both for drinking water
and for wastewater state state aid
grants
uh those conflict conflict a little bit
with the
the budget size wanted the budget
requests i just want to draw your
attention to that
just for background uh you probably most
of you already know this
but the state of grant programs and
after the fact reimbursement
usually for about 20 of the project cost
and historically uh
it's been done for uh wastewater
treatment plants so
uh clean water uh which is the term of
art for that
uh so uh so these two
two bills since i'm talking about them
the the drinking water systems grant
bill
uh i'll draw your attention to our
testimony letter my testimony letter
on that uh unlike clean water
the clean water state a grant where
we've we've had that program off and on
running for a while with existing staff
uh the drinking water program uh
for state aid grant hasn't uh basically
hasn't existed since 2008
there was a small amount in 2011. so so
we have no
program to administer that right now
there's not the staffing for that so
we'd have to stand up
that and uh again i know it's a little
bit outside the budget
per se but it's related uh and uh so
are suggesting in that my suggestion in
that letter was
there's the state revolving loan fund
there's a drinking water grower
trust fund there's this new pfast loan
fund uh
and that may be a better way more
efficient way rather than standing up
uh staff to do a new program so i just
want to draw your attention to that and
again as always we can answer questions
uh for that there are issues and sue
carlson can talk to
uh on uh the state a grant
is in the uh operating budget to the
extent that
uh prior work was done
by 2019 uh and we also had existing
um obligations met so if the project
effectively the the requests had gone
through the government council already
uh so certainly sue can answer more
questions if you have on that
and then almost wrapping up here on
slide 24.
uh again as i mentioned uh on house bill
we're asked to comment on that uh
section
59 extends the date for the
i mentioned that we had gotten six
million dollars
out of the drinking water groundwater
trust fund it extends the date
uh for that that money as far as the sun
setting
for us uh in section 60 i think they're
all on
page 26 of house bill 2
uh establishes a moratorium on new state
aid grants
and then of course we will pay attention
to
a lot of hospital too as you're well
aware talks about the department of
energy so to the extent there's any uh
overlap
uh we'll we'll pay attention to that
issue also so with that i i don't want
to ramble on too much more than i have
uh and we're very happy to answer any
questions
thanks mr chairman so you said earlier
you had a number of
unfunded or vacant positions i think he
said
something like 89. are those all
funded or are not funded yes
those are all funded those are all
funded okay
so as you're well aware that during the
the hyder covid you know we
we were basically just about filling
positions so that that kind of added to
that and then of course we have the
normal
sequence of retirements and people
moving on and that type of thing
further follow-up thanks so i'm looking
at
dam operations excuse me
on page 761 and i
saw where in other areas where
electricity heat water had
stayed the same or gone down but on this
particular line out of
23 it's going roughly from six thousand
dollars a year to sixteen
thousand dollars can you explain why
that's up so high
i'm gonna let my chief operating officer
try to take a stab at that i'm gonna put
her on the spot thank you
yes um what we were seeing is a
large increase in electric rates um
at our dams and as we convert dams from
manual operations to
automated operations
that obviously increases our utility
bills
to run those automated systems and
that's what's driving the increase
no further go ahead further okay
uh also there uh i see that
you're reducing the number of staff from
eight to seven and there were some other
areas like wetlands you're reducing
staff from like nine to eight could you
tell us why you're reducing in those
areas
essentially what we did was we moved
staff
around in this case
under dam operations um what we did is
they
had a position that they were not using
so we converted that position um
to a paralegal position and actually
moved it
from this account up to
the thousand and two account which you
and in wetlands what you will see with
what we did was we moved
um one of our positions that was a
general fund position
to one of the fee accounts and we did
that to stay within the governor's
budget um recommendation on reduction in
all right uh mr chairman i'll let
someone else go but i do have a
further question aren't you you're on a
roll okay thanks
so i know this is a question for you sue
or mike wimsett but i had a question on
uh
you know we've seen you know we've
talked about this in the past mike
uh all the solid waste issues in the
state there was a committee forum
some time ago that looked into this and
was concerned that whereas some states
like vermont is beginning food waste
massachusetts is banning
construction waste we're still accepting
all of this here in the state is the
state looking any further
in regulating what we have so we have
room to dispose of our waste instead of
accepting a lot of the waste from states
around us
sure thank you representative eastman
for the question so so there's been a
tremendous amount of
interest in the whole topic of solid
waste management particularly with
regard to recycling and diversion
you know from technologies for diverting
solid waste from landfill disposal
we do have a lot of work going on we
were actually pretty excited we have
been
under-resourced in this program for a
long time in terms of not having the
available staff to work on those types
of initiatives
and we actually have a uh reorganization
playing in with the division of
personnel right now
and we have in this proposal the
governor's budget
on positions and an organizational
structure that'll help us start to focus
on those things so we're very optimistic
about that we're also going to be
working
on a state solid waste management plan
um that will
and we expect to be engaging uh
stakeholders from across the
panoply of interest there so it'll
include uh you know legislators
and members of the public waste industry
representatives and
business communities so we're we're
really excited about that in the future
but it's it's
it is certainly true that our ability to
address those kinds of issues
in recent years has been pretty limited
so just a quick follow-up
good thanks mr chairman so you're saying
mike that
it looks a little brighter than it did
maybe two years ago
you know there was a like i said maybe
earlier there was a group a committee
commission
that looked at it was very concerned so
you see some
opportunities to address some of these
concerns
i do and actually that that that
committee that was pulled together
i think was house bill 617 um really was
a
kind of a catalyst for that they met
they had i think a number of meetings in
just two months i think they met
something like 14
times they heard from about 50 witnesses
and they really collected a lot of
information and kind of developed a road
map for the kinds of things that
that we want to be working on and i i
would go so far as to say i think we
enjoy
um more interest and support both from
in our you know within our own des
leadership
and in the governor's office in the
legislature than we've ever seen before
so i'm very optimistic that the co in
the coming couple of years we're going
to be
doing some really good work in that area
i know we have a lot of faith in you
mike so
good luck thanks mr chairman
representative okay thank you mr
chairman
uh thank you commissioner scott for
being here and i i really appreciate
your handout because
the fonts are large enough for me to
read i greatly appreciate that
um i apologize for uh my ignorance
uh i was surprised to see that you do
loans are those loans to municipalities
could you clarify that for me please
sure so there's
two major now three uh loan programs
that we have so the the state revolving
loan program
so we have one for drinking water
which is what it says the other one's
for clean water
uh and that's a term of art so you know
when you hear clean water think of
actually waste water to clean the waste
water
uh or storm water that type of thing and
then the third
new loan fund is uh
fast uh impacted uh uh
entities and then to complicate things
even more we have the drinking water
groundwater trust fund which does loans
and does grants uh and that's again for
drinking water
so uh the srf programs
uh uh hopefully somebody will correct me
if i get it wrong but
the sr programs are start on a federal
appropriation so we have two major
accounts there
uh the the the money we get from the
feds and then since they are
loans even though they can have certain
amount of loan forgiveness
uh we also have an account for their
repayment funds which we again
then turn back out uh so short answer is
yes
uh primarily uh these go to
municipalities
for their water and clean water
infrastructure projects
follow up yeah follow up also in
what is the interest rates uh involved
for these loans to the municipalities
sure i want to talk about the latest one
latest interest rate
um good afternoon yes for the clean
water
our interest rate is set at two percent
and for drinking water
it is a variable rate starting i think
at 1.58 and going up
if you were to check our website
we set the rates once a year every fall
and those rates hold for the entire year
and we can send you that link if you
would like
okay thank you uh follow up uh are those
rates compounded or is it a flat rate
what we do is under epa guidelines
we follow what is called the uh 11-year
geo bond rating
to use as the base for setting our
thank you if i could add as
sue mentioned it we're really under they
are relatively low compared to others
generally speaking so they're attractive
um
but they are are uh you know we're under
federal guidelines on how we set those
so it's not
it's not at our whim uh the other
probably downside to
the srf loans in some respects is the
federal cross cutters because
because the genesis of this is federal
money so
wage reporting or american steel
requirements that type of thing so
so there is a little bit of
administrative cost to taking these
loans that
that other monies may not have
associated
thank you other questions
commissioner i have a question uh on
your handout
you reference section 191 which is the
creation of the department of energy
and now that goes on many many sections
after that
my question is just in maybe from the 30
000 foot level what
what is the effect of this department or
the interaction with this department or
your your issues plus or minus
with this reorg so a few things and
none of them are i won't say we have any
major uh
uh issues with the legislation uh or
our interactions but right now my staff
deal with uh
osi office of special initiatives on for
instance
uh the state is in receipt of uh
funds from the volkswagen diesel
settlement
we work with them on 15
of those funds go to electrification for
uh electric vehicles in the state
uh we do uh with with them at osi
we work on the there's some federal
money that comes in for
diesel emissions retrofit or diesel
missions retrofit act
uh funds from congress that we we kind
of work with osi
on so we have interactions with that
will of course be subsumed
into the new department of energy so we
have those interactions
uh we have a seat on the energy
efficiency and sustainable
energy board uh so that's that will be
at least administratively assigned in
some respects
to uh to that agency
uh i'm vice chair of the site evaluation
committee uh by statute
uh that will will then be
administratively attached to the
department of energy
uh so so those are the type of things so
it's more on the peripheral
if you will okay thank you
other questions
[Music]
you're in the governor's budget book
you'll be you start on page 713
and go on quite a ways
uh i would ask miss carlson if
if you have any pages you'd like us to
particularly note where there's
variances that might catch one's eye
because sitting here paging through this
entire book
could could be a laborious process
we tried in our presentation to identify
those areas where we had significant
changes
in the budget um just so that you didn't
have to go through all 135 pages of our
budget
if i don't have a particular pages
um for you to suggest other than the
ones we have already given you
that's fine i just so the two again
our biggest thing if you let me let me
show you where our single biggest change
is in
and that is down
on page 833
and that is um account 8873 which is our
emerging contaminated account
that um shows where we have um
where the pfast money is being budgeted
for 22 and 23.
and that's the one program that had the
one of the most significant changes to
representation thanks mr chairman
another issue of concern is uh in the
past damn maintenance and i see you've
gone up
some well fairly significantly there
uh how are we doing on the dams and the
maintenance of all the dams that are
under your
jurisdiction so
uh on the capital budget side we
actually had a
fair increase uh because of that so we
have two issues i i think i called out
for you
on uh page 787
the extra million dollar for the uh
some of our state-owned dams from
federal money for an assessment
on the capital budget we're also looking
at uh asset management help
on on our dams also so
short answer is is uh you know we the
capital budget and operating budget work
for us this cycle
uh i will say as a
word of things to come for future
budgets uh the
the closer we look at our dams and we're
again we're we're doing some work to get
uh
contract work to look at our dams also
the more we're finding so
uh you know to be blunt uh you know one
of the things i have an ear towards
right now
is to the extent there's monies coming
from the feds that could be used for
this type of thing that may be a good
way to
get us uh back on an even keel if you
will for the future
uh but by and large it's something that
that looms large on our
radar screen and uh you know
without you know maybe federal funds
come to help us on that end
you'll see a larger especially on the
capital budget side
uh a larger request than than we have
in the past uh to keep our dams uh
uh whole if you will thanks thanks mr
trump
okay do you have any
any comments you'd like to offer the
workshop at this time so it just to
follow up on
uh representative leitchman's last
question so to give you an idea the
average age of our state-owned dams is
as rough
as is a little over 100 years old right
so we're
we have a an aging fleet if you will so
and as always obviously i hope you know
this but
if we can answer any questions or
anything you have
as a committee after thoughts please
feel free to let us know too we'll
get right on that and get you answers
legislature
there being none i would say thank you
for coming
um and we'll look forward to seeing you
in a couple of years
okay well thank you very much as far as
the committee goes
uh we will reconvene tuesday morning at
nine o'clock
at that time we'll be considering five i
believe it's five bills now
4 25 was waived off so we
will see you next tuesday at nine
o'clock
so this question
i think that's what the chair the chair
planned was yeah
yes yeah yeah it's like getting your
teeth drilled no novocaine
so mr chairman yes um
do you know if copies of the bills are
uh i could i can ask i don't i send dana
uh email for that for you too oh did you
okay
to make sure we're getting them i think
so great
all right no further business we are
adjourned
peace